ha hello I'm brie Larson and I will be
answering fan questions while playing
with puppies hello baby
hi wait more I get two three oh my gosh
no way come on join the party baby was
at my lab - angels
[Music]
well vector baby I did have hesitations
because I was I didn't know that I would
do interviews with puppies I didn't know
that was part of the contract I thought
that I was actually scared of this part
of the process the idea of like my face
being places and dealing with the sort
of like Fame stuff was not a super
appealing to me because I am an
introvert so I needed to take a little
bit of time to see if I could kind of
handle the leadership position of this
part but I didn't have any issue with
you know the character in the movie or
what they were trying to do with it in
fact I was really excited about which
was why it was kind of a difficult
decision but um I'm really glad I did it
and it feels like a like a giant win for
introverts everywhere it was just a very
simple moment I was in a wardrobe
fitting and I didn't even know it was
happening I had tried on various pieces
of the costume and he kind of do like a
fitting for the boots fitting for the
pants but in for the top fitting for the
helmet and so I didn't I didn't know
that I was finally gonna put it all on
for the first time and it takes like a
couple people to put it all on and I was
talking and wasn't paying attention and
suddenly I looked in the mirror I was
like oh my gosh it looks like a
Disneyland character and then I just was
like really concerned about going to the
bathroom I'm also like a woman so I I
have a menstruation and that was also
scary to me I was like what do I do
how do superheroes do this but they were
super awesome and had tons of extra you
know zippers and ways that I could get
out of it still takes like 30 minutes to
get out of it to go to the bathroom but
it's fine
[Music]
it impacted me in that it made me from a
very beginning I mean just deciding to
take on the role meant that I was going
outside of my comfort zone and gonna
push myself to do things that were I
don't know things that I never thought
that I could do whether it was dead
lifting or learning martial arts things
like that well those are all very new
for me I don't know I have no
expectations how it impacts people you
know I don't really I don't really know
I don't really feel like it's up to me
oh you came back you came back to me why
is that so satisfying
I feel like accepted and understood and
seeing oh that's an expensive shoe hmm
there's a couple things for different
reasons that were intense so there's a
ropes course scene in the movie and we
did that 50 feet up in the air on wires
and I had to learn how to do these like
kind of like flip around y-your kick
things that was pretty cool and new and
also like the the thing I think it's
like in the trailer I think people have
seen it now I'm hanging on the side of a
train and I sort of pull myself up and
go into a shoulder roll and then blast
oh also the in the mine frac sequence
when I'm hanging upside down so I'm
hanging by my ankles and I have to you
know use my abs to lift myself up break
the restraints and then flip around and
land that took like you know saw what
weekend to learn how to get right
[Music]
uh I really AM into butterfly clips I
also keep thinking about hit clips I
don't know if anybody else remembers
those but they were like 62nd like
little microchips that you could buy at
McDonald's that played like NSYNC and
Backstreet Boys I don't know why I so
badly want those to come back cuz
they're really not practical but I like
it there's a lot of stuff I work our
team was like the first to you SIL that
all the toys in the world and you just
want a very expensive shoe it was like
an hour and a half every day for six
months and then three months before we
started shooting we'd do two a days and
the two days work we're still doing that
hour and a half of like cardio and come
back here you are hilarious
love your spirit cardio and
weightlifting but then we added in fight
training so I'd work with the stunt team
for two hours and kind of do like the
making of a future superhero stuff like
learning footwork and punches and kicks
and wire works like literally learning
how to fly and then other than that you
just drink a lot of water and eat a lot
of food oh yeah you're into that what
was the question
[Music]
a real-life role model is my mom for
sure and then like I love the Spice
Girls
I loved Sailor Moon I'd like to come
home from school just to try to not miss
a second of Sailor Moon it did read
Wonder Woman comics growing up so maybe
some of that yeah I think I mean the
float on blasters super cool but the
more I think about it the more I feel
like flying is probably like the most
practical application I could use for my
life yeah I mean I don't even need to
cut it for a movie oh I've had my hair
that short before I kind of been
thinking about doing it to be honest
because it's less work
I feel like at this point of my life I'm
probably the most like Carol than
anything but it's also just because like
she's such an empowering role whereas I
feel like most of the things I did
before were more dramatic okay so when
those movies were done I was like leave
that experience behind but after playing
Carol for close to a year basically once
it was all said and done I I just I dig
her vibe and I feel like a lot of the
way that she views the world and in
particular how she owns and views
herself I think is empowering and
helpful to me I've just decided to be a
little bit more like her I can tell you
nothing absolutely nothing so this was
me doing an interview while playing with
puppies and I wish you would never end I
want to thank the best friend Animal
Society for allowing me to play with
these beautiful puppies please go to
their website best friends org to find
your best friend today are you sure you
don't ask me more questions
[Music]
you